sette anni che vivo qui quando ho
conosciuto con il sensei racconta ho
conosciuto tutte queste
non sentivo niente qui grazie 16 se
raccontato ho tutti questi cari amici è
una bella energia che io come mai se ho
chiesto lì non mi stanco mai di darle ma
mai
è troppo bella presidente grazie a
livello medico cioè quella gente di kim
dicevano gli attori ad essi sono il
primo qui e finisco di fare lezioni a
cui stiamo qui fino alle 2 di notte ha
fatto vivere da via torre di strass e in
essa al colore bianco nero non c'è
differenza fatto noi facciamo il grande
spettacolo con tutti il coloro cui
martis
allora 167 contatto è un progetto di
contatto fra le persone di costruzione
di senso di comunità quella che vediamo
e la zona stazione di reggio emilia la
zona stazione di reggio emilia è
storicamente una zona ad alto tasso di
immigrati un grande turnover una
situazione diciamo
esplosiva comunque faticosa da diversi
anni per la città di reggio emilia e di
fatto noi viviamo in una società del web
2.0 dove fondamentalmente il contatto
soprattutto quello virtuale
siamo tutti abituati a praticarlo con
facebook con i social network attraverso
appunto il computer oppure attraverso le
immagini di fatto il contatto quello
vero deve essere reale e allora lo
spunto che ha portato cinque anni fa a
costruire il progetto 16 set raccontato
e quello che
intervenire da un punto di vista
culturale per risolvere il problema o
comunque per affrontare il problema del
del dialogo tra le persone e deve essere
fatto attraverso un progetto che possa
durare nel tempo e quindi se
se prima per carità si possono pensare
comunque degli eventi spot che possano
portare socialità per qualche momento in
una area di una città
e chiaro che più interessante
sicuramente lavorare su un progetto
diciamo che parte dal basso e che
coinvolga i cittadini di quel quartiere
ma anche di tutta la città per costruire
appunto qualcosa che coinvolga tutti
quanti
quindi sono stati attivati una serie di
laboratori condotti da esperti e questi
laboratori
quindi sono frequentati da allievi
reggiani
stranieri cittadini di varietà e
frequentano quindi una zona è stata fra
virgolette abbandonata nel tempo
comunque è stata considerata pericolosa
faticosa da da affrontare e di fatto nei
mesi quindi viene abitata questa zona
per costruire qualcosa
in parallelo viene è stato attivato un
tavolo di lavoro trasversale e coinvolge
tutte le associazioni le istituzioni
tutte le realtà del territorio che a
diverso titolo si occupano o si vogliono
occupare del dialogo interculturale
ne deriva poi un festival nel mese di
giugno che prevede quindi la
restituzione dei laboratori e poi
chiaramente anche eventi di vario genere
sempre legati al tema del dialogo da
dibattiti approfondimenti
abbiamo avuto anche spettacoli di un
certo di un certo rilievo
però il tutto abbiamo avuto per esempio
come ospite fiorella mannoia che l'anno
scorso ha scritto un disco sul sul tema
del proprio del dialogo interculturale e
quindi l'idea è quella che tutti insieme
si possa costruire un pezzo di contatto
che possa mettere in relazione alle
persone e una un'idea semplice
esportabile e copiabile di fatto
sappiamo benissimo noi stessi ci siamo
gemellati virtualmente con altre realtà
del territorio limitrofo tipo bologna o
forlì che come la parto come il rock che
fondamentalmente gestiscono questo
questo tema nello stesso modo magari con
con approcci differenti che partono
magari da da altri spunti ma di fatto il
sistema è sempre quello quello di
costruire un evento condiviso e che
sfocia poi in un grande corteo dove di
fatto i cittadini e le persone diciamo
di di varie delle varie realtà anche
anche semplici passanti possono unirsi a
questo corteo e festeggiare no poi non
mancano ovviamente momenti di
convivialità il cibo è sempre un altro
un'altra ottima occasione per per
costruire un
senso di appartenenza e in una società
come la nostra che sicuramente ha il
problema di non sapere più dove che
direzione prendere c'è la crisi non
senti fatto si pensa che lo spettacolo e
la cultura siano elementi trascurabili
in realtà al di là delle telecamere al
di là di quelli che sono diciamo gli
interventi di ordine pubblico
sicuramente il maggiore ordine che uno
può pensare di ottenere quello della
conoscenza e quello del conoscersi del
frequentarsi e del creare relazioni e
questo quindi a questo punto io di passo
la parola al questo momento clou del 167
contatto che è il grande corteo lo
vediamo in video e poi magari
partecipiamo anche noi tutti insieme a
questo corteo
che non mi piace no sembrano nascondere
qualcosa di negativo
ci piacciono non ci piaccia dobbiamo
convivere in questa città in questo
quartiere in questo spazio nel
porterò mi viene in mente un'altra
parole allora per farmela piacere penso
che convivono due persone che si amano
questo rende bello il tempo convivenza è
una danza
continuamente ci si avvicina chi si
allontana fino a comporre una distanza
una vicinanza che ci permette di dire ad
alta voce e bene e tu esiste
esiste
nella valle pata noi persona è
amministrata arrivano di torno in modo
che la propria condotta su
distinsero più il sole pianeta t finity
oriali e programmati beccate sono grandi
e colorate calde d'inverno e fresche
l'estate per ogni abitante non c'è
diversità
secondo e vorrei di sua maestà la corte
decide il modo di vestire la lingua da
banale non applicare pira in questa
forzata uniformità non c'è neanche un
barlume di libertà di chiedo di cantare
ballare e nei locali pubblici
lieto di pensare
c'era la signora che aveva più degli
anni che dimostrava e conosceva di
storie di tutti l'ira persista della
musica del rapitore di laura anche il
portafogli a me è una città di marzapane
canditi e cioccolato dove si mangiava di
notte e di giorno e non si piazzava
adam inizierà sempre profumo di pane
sera l'accoltella con i pesci angelo i
bambini ci giocavano ad amici voglio
andare perché la città dell'amore
la città più l'anima dei luoghi se solo
avessimo pagato il mio stile
adesso saremmo stati felici
che invece il debito che non si metteva
mai di pagare di essere sopravvissuti ai
nostri figli
la città senza bollini moto sono solo
dietro
oggi america è una città dove tutti
corrono in cunicoli di blocco come
branchi di topi si strappano le avanzi
caduti dai denti dei giochi più
minacciosi che piazza un pirata degli
altri solo ai non brero diffidenti le
palpebre sono pesanti sui quali c'è
gente che crede di volare invece si alza
spesa dal suolo aspetto anche malandra
aver visto quanto si dovrà vedere per
potersi aprire lo spiraglio quando
apparirà la cittadinanza forte tutto
star sapere quali parole pronunciare
quali genti cose e basterà che qualcuno
faccia qualcosa per il solo piacere di
fatah e il suo piacere
gli altri
in quel momento tutti l'impatto italiano
le altezze le ditate l'assenza si
trasfigura diventa trasparente e
cristallina come la livella ma bisogna
che tutto cambi come per caso senza dare
troppo importanza
di avere la pediatra di sta compiendo
un'azione decisiva sono quasi tutti
volevamo come de nobili milan cielo
d'estate
grazie ad alessandro scillitani
e a questo viaggio molto probabile
sia al mini corteo e soprattutto al
vostro progetto 167 contatto grazie
innanzitutto a tutti voi che ci avete
seguito qui in diretta a reggio emilia a
questo telex piazza del tricolore ma
anche a coloro che ci hanno seguito in
differita sul nostro sito dell'ex piazza
del tricolore punto com io non posso non
menzionare non pronunciare
insomma i nomi delle persone che hanno
reso possibile che questa polis oggi in
questa nostra piazza del tricolore
possa ha potuto avere forma e in questi
in una mattinata di 2 febbraio molto
piovosa ci siamo tutti fermati per un
attimo abbiamo condiviso le idee ma più
che altro ci siamo incuriositi perché
questo tedax piazza del tricolore
oltre questo nostro primo appuntamento
di nuove idee per convivere possa anche
continuare in futuro pensando e creando
le idee che vale la pena di fondere
allora innanzitutto
ringrazio alessandro schiatti paolo
tegoni mariana bellesi nicoletta
bernazzani maura catellani andrea bassi
marco marmiroli cristina fabri caterina
tognon agnesi spinelli elena mazzali e
tutti voi ancora per averci seguito e
speriamo che ci vediamo insieme in un
altro polis in un altro terex piazza del
tricolore grazie